[Music]
all right let's move on now and talk
about Chris Pratt and on a ferris Chris
is making his very first public
appearance since they're shocking split
and here is what we know now less than a
week after announcing his separation
from wife of eight years on ax we've
learned Chris's confirmed to be at the
Teen Choice Awards in Los Angeles this
Sunday as a nominee no word yet on his
plus-one we hope he brings almost
five-year-old son Jack with them it's
been 13 years since Chris has attended
the award show the last time was 2004 as
the nominee with his Everwood co-star
Gregory Smith getting ready to plug away
another another season we're all very
excited and you know grateful to be
working so so yeah it's good this time
Chris is up for two coveted surfboards
choice movie ship for his on-screen
chemistry with co-star Zoe Saldana is
that a rifle you didn't know what a
rifle looks like and choice sci-fi movie
actor for his role as star-lord do you
need a hug no no I do not also on the
guest list this weekend Miley Cyrus
accepting the show's highest honor the
ultimate Choice Award
now after Sunday's team choice 2017
Chris will get a little bit of a break
from any film promotion is pressed to
her for both his upcoming films Avengers
affinity war and Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom won't begin till next year
[Music]
you